I would now like to calculate
the moment of inertia
for a very thin disk.
So we have a thin disk.
And the radius of
that disk is r.
And it has a mass m.
And I would like to calculate
the moment of inertia
for this disk.
Now, let's just
remind what point
we're calculating it about,
about the center of mass.
So our definition
of moment of inertia
was take a small element,
mass element to the disk.
In fact, we're going to see
it doesn't have to be small.
Take a mass element to
the disk that's useful,
and multiply it by the
perpendicular distance squared
from the point we're
calculating it.
So the way I'll do it
is I will choose a ring.
I'm gonna choose a
ring of radius r.
And now I'll make the
ring a certain thickness.
And this thickness is dr.
Now, in this
calculation, we're going
to take a limit as
dr goes to zero.
So even though the ring
has some finite thickness,
its radius-- we'll
eventually treat
treated as all of
the mass element
a distance r from the center.
So r will be our
integration variable.
And that will be equal to
rcm, what we're calling
rcm in the abstract result.
Now, the dm is the tricky part.
So what is the mass that's
contained in this area disk
of radius r and thickness dr?
Well, one way to think
about that is it's-- here we
didn't say this, but our
disk is going to be uniform.
And so we can describe
the mass per unit area
as the total mass divided by
the area of the whole disk.
And then we can say that
the mass in that ring
is equal to sigma
mass per area times
the area of the outer ring minus
the area of the inner ring.
Now, when we expand this
out, dm, m over pi r squared,
we get pi r squared plus
2rdr plus dr quantity
squared minus pi r squared.
And you can see
those terms cancel.
And so what I get is
m times pi r squared.
And in here I have
2 pi r dr. Now,
this is only order
dr, plus a second term
that goes like pi dr squared.
And so, when I take this
limit as dr goes to 0,
this term is much, much
smaller than that term.
And so I can say my mass
element is m pi r squared times
2 pi r dr.
Now, let's think about this
term, why it makes sense.
When we're shrinking our
ring, so taking a limit as dr
goes to 0, and the ring just
becomes an extremely thin ring
at radius r, then this
piece is a circumference,
and this piece is
just the width.
And so it's no surprise
that area is 2 pi r
times d pi r dr in the limit.
And now that enables us to
write the moment of inertia
about the center of mass, icm.
Let's pull out these
constants, m pi r squared.
Now we're integrating
over the body.
Let's hold off on the
limits for the moment,
and put our values for dm.
That's 2 pi r dr. And we
have our distance squared,
which was, again, the
radius of r squared.
And so the pis will cancel.
I have 2m over r-squared times
the integral of r cubed dr.
Now, we're supposedly
integrating over the body,
but what does that body
integral actually mean?
Well, what we're doing is
we're taking a series of rings
and adding them up as
we go from the origin
out to the radius
of the whole disk.
So the limits of our body
integral with respect
to our integration variable,
we start with rings
that essentially have no width.
And we're integrating
these, we're adding up
the contribution of
every ring until we
get to rings of radius r.
And our integration
variable, r cubed, dr.
Now, this is an integral
that's easy to do.
That's r to the forth over
4 between 0 and r equals r.
And when we put that
in, the 2 cancels the 4.
And oh, the pi we lost.
So let's make sure
this pi should be in m.
So we have the 2 over the 4
is one half, and r squared.
And that is the moment
of inertia of it
does about an axis
passing through the center
perpendicular to the
plane of the disk.